Johnny Knoxville burst onto the showbiz scene
in 2000 as the de facto host of MTV's Jackass,
a strange, hysterically funny reality show
that became a surprise smash hit and launched
Knoxville to stardom.
"Hi I'm Johnny Knoxville, welcome to Jackass!"
He followed it up with three hit Jackass movies
and acting roles in several other films.
And then Knoxville…pretty much up and vanished.
Why?
Here's a look at the real reasons we don't
hear from Johnny Knoxville anymore.
He's not much of an actor
Johnny Knoxville may be a star, but that doesn't
make him an actor.
After the success of Jackass on both the small
and big screens, Knoxville landed roles in
films like The Dukes of Hazzard, Walking Tall,
and A Dirty Shame.
And the less said about The Ringer, the better.
"Do you need a hug?"
"Jeffy doesn't know what's happening to his
body."
"Ok."
None of them did well at the box office or
with critics.
His only live action acting role in a successful
film came way back in 2002 with Men in Black
II, where he played the same kind of slightly
dumb mischief-maker that he's played in just
about all of his films.
With that kind of box office record and industry
typecasting, it's no wonder we haven't seen
much of him at the multiplex recently.
"I think I'm gonna be sick."
"You don't wanna do that."
Wounded warrior
This won't come as much of a surprise, but
Knoxville sustained a number of injuries over
the years working on Jackass.
On the set of the original TV show, an ankle
sprain forced Knoxville to wear a brace for
most of the first season, while on the first
Jackass movie, he was knocked out cold — twice.
Knoxville would later top that in Jackass
Number Two, claiming he nearly died when a
rocket blew up on him during a stunt.
"3...2...1...go!"
"Hahaha ahahaha!"
Yet no amount of concussions could compare
to Knoxville's worst injury: he broke his
own penis and tore his urethra when a 400-pound
motorcycle landed on his groin.
To this day, Knoxville must use a catheter
twice a day.
"Why couldn't I have got a broken arm or leg,
or like broken collar - but no!
I got blood shootin' out of my peepee."
With so many injuries plaguing him, Knoxville
just isn't able to do as much in general as
he used to, which may have led to less time
in front of the cameras overall.
A Jackass no more
While the fame brought on by Jackass helped
Knoxville branch out into acting, it also
posed an immediate problem: how could an ultra-famous
star continue to perform pranks on an unsuspecting
public?
Well, the films addressed this by sending
Knoxville overseas to perform his stunts,
filming in Japan, Russia, and India.
And that costs a lot of money, time, and resources,
meaning Knoxville may have actually become
more famous than he can afford to be.
"Hello my name's Johnny Knoxville and I'm
about to end this movie!"
Ryan Dunn's death
The Jackass franchise took a major hit in
2011 when Knoxville's co-star and close friend
Ryan Dunn died in a car accident at age 34.
Following Dunn's death, Knoxville released
a public statement that read,
"You'll have to excuse me, I'm just very sad
because I lost my brother and my world got
about 134-percent less funny.
I don't know what else to say right now, so
I will close with I love you, Ryan.
I have a lot of emotions swirling, but I want
you to know I love you so very much."
Shortly after Dunn's death, Knoxville spun
off from the Jackass brand with the 2013 comedy
Bad Grandpa, which blended hidden-camera pranks
with a scripted story.
The film proved to be a financial success
and may have shown Knoxville a way forward
despite losing Dunn — and without Jackass.
Smaller projects
It's not so much that Knoxville has left the
spotlight than the spotlight has left him.
Knoxville has continued to work on smaller
projects that simply haven't gotten as much
attention as Jackass once brought, like the
2013 Arnold Schwarzenegger flop, The Last
Stand.
Following his semi-scripted turn in Bad Grandpa,
Knoxville worked on two independent projects,
both slated for release in 2016: Weightless,
opposite Julianne Nicholson, and Above Suspicion,
with Game of Thrones star Emilia Clarke.
Working on indie dramas like these could help
Knoxville finally get out of Hollywood typecast
jail.
"Oh we gonna have to get out of here."
Not the tabloid type
Finally, this may come as a surprise to some
fans, but Johnny Knoxville has a happy life
as a family man.
A father of three, he actually credits impending
fatherhood with helping him jump-start his
career.
Before the birth of his oldest daughter Madison,
and in need of money to support his forthcoming
family, he brainstormed an idea that would
eventually change his life.
"I saw something on TV where a guy pepper
sprayed himself.
And I thought, 'Well that's a really good
idea, that'd be a really good article, if
I could test different types of self-defense
equipment on myself.'
And it was just an article, but Jeff said
'You should, we'll film it for ya too.'"
Those videos proved to be so hilarious that
they are what originally led to the creation
of Jackass.
That's put food on the table, but his quiet
family life and happy marriage to second wife
Naomi Nelson have kept paparazzi away and
helped Knoxville avoid the harsh glare of
the tabloid spotlight.
He's earned the break.
"Hey is this okay?
Then we're good."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you want to see from Johnny Knoxville next...